c'est à l'intérieur du château de vie à
ecully que sera créée l'an prochain la
première école nationale supérieure des
arts culinaires ici dans ce parc de 7
hectares pendant trois ans seront formés
les plus grands responsables des
entreprises de restauration
un voeu cher aux professionnels de la
gastronomie française
une proposition faite par jean ferniot
dans le rapport qu'il a remis il ya un
mois au premier ministre l'objectif
concurrencer les grandes écoles comme
lausanne qui fournissent actuellement
dans le monde entier les meilleurs
serveurs maîtres d'hôtel ou sommelier un
débouché pour nos produits notre
vaisselle et nova paul bocuse alain
chapel georges blanc dans la région ont
été des fervents défenseurs de cette
idée le ministre la culture les a donc
suivi en décidant la création de cette
école dans la région lyonnaise montant
des premières subventions 6 millions de
francs en france on a beaucoup de chefs
c'est derrière ces écoles d'une part
fois que ça va être pour former des
chapelles des trois gros les vhs à
mettre pour faire des chefs exécutifs et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que les
chevilles dans le monde sont bientôt des
japonais parce que les japonais pourquoi
ça parce que le français parlent pas
assez l'anglais je crois qu'avant tout
il faut que ces élèves parlent anglais
couramment et après bien sûr et confère
une très bonne formation
vous avez une des courses et écoles des
cours vous n'êtes pas mais parce que
vous avez dans une école cd20 moment où
il faut être à temps complet mais
comptait y aura des cours du temps en
temps de chapelle de travaux
berger les meilleures huîtres ens de
lyon et il faut y croire arriver là pour
un métier continue il faut savoir
transmettre ce qui est important il faut
transmettre